blue you're insane what what oh shut off
me you crazy dog we're gonna go see a
movie today hey guys what's up what do
you face what I do today do I go sleep
and you're watching movie of me and
Damien huh so what movie are we seeing
Damien I said
Mars Mars Needs Moms and why in the
world are we seeing that mostly because
you suggested it I'm sorry it looks like
it could be mildly funny in fact I might
just give it a mildly enjoyable rating
we'll see what happens Mars Needs Moms
is the new CGI animated children's
comedy of the month that seems like
quite a bit of these come out and lately
actually the animated movies have been
really good like Rango you know Toy
Story 3 How to Train Your Dragon and I
just called up my buddy Damien and said
hey you know what what are you doing
tonight I sawed off the other hose it
came out this weekend you want to see
this Mars Needs Moms movie you know I
mean I'm glad I have friends like Damien
TIFF because I didn't now Tris it would
be by myself Damien's sister came along
and it was just us during the theater
that's not really a good sign for the
movie but it was kind of cool because it
was like we had our own little screening
it's about a kid who has a fight with
his mom and he says she doesn't want her
anymore
that night aliens abduct her and he
accidentally stowaway on the ship and
gets launched to Mars and it's a big
race to try to find his mom because
apparently Mars does a whole bunch of
Martian babies that are hatching and
they need mothers to to use the mothers
disciplinary consciousness to be able to
insert it into these robots that take
care of the babies on Mars yeah it's
this kind of a way to get the son to
realize he needs his mother still but
the way they go about the plot is just
it's so strange actually an
that I think about it I said they're
watching the movie and for a long time I
didn't really mind it but as the film
progressed towards the end and towards
the finale it just kept getting so odd a
few the characters were silly and funny
at times but really the biggest fly out
of this movie it's not funny I've really
laughed at all there are certain
comedies that are made for people of all
ages like Toy Story but this film is
strictly for children Robert Zemeckis
produced this film and it utilizes his
motion capture technology that he used
on films like Beowulf or the Polar
Express or Christmas Carol a lot of the
motions were really well done the
physicality of the of it was really good
the motion is just it's just not there
it's it's you can tell that it's not
real during the end credits they rolled
sequences of showing the actual actors
and the suits and everything and Damon
was like man if they put so much work
into him surprise the characterizations
were so dull so Damian he's an art major
and he was able to see you know these
characters they just don't have a lot of
life that's supposed to be their script
is very weird
sometimes a little cliched there's a lot
of odd things going on to the point of
interplanetary species or romance that I
didn't really understand some of the
action sequences are interesting it's
all kind of watchable now Seth Green
modeled as the boy in this film and did
the voice but after watching all of his
work they decided to replace his voice
with someone else and still use his face
and everything it's kind of strange how
they did that and they didn't notice
that his voice didn't sound anything
like a kids while they were filming this
is one of those films that is all very
very technical and the film tries to be
very emotional at times and it just
doesn't work out I'm giving it the same
rating I gave all the other films that
came out this weekend two out of four
this film read writing and battle Los
Angeles are all just very underwhelming
I suggest you see Adjustment Bureau or
Rango in all honesty sorry guys this
weekend kind of sucks
Mars Needs Moms new Disney Mars Needs
Moms
Mars Needs Moms is the new Disney CGI
animated comedy movie Mars Needs Moms